Last week, a senior vice president of Google
quietly parachuted from 135,890 feet, breaking
the sound barrier in the process.
How is it that a human can fall faster than
sound?
Hey guys, Amy here for DNews, and to call
the sound barrier a “barrier” is actually
a bit of a misnomer.
Anything moving through the air, like an airplane,
has to push air molecules out of its way to
move.
This forms a pressure wave in front of and
behind the airplane, and the faster that airplane
flies the faster those molecules have to move
out of the way.
The pressure waves start to compress.
At a certain point, the molecules can’t
get out the way fast enough and.
They form a “barrier” in front of the
airplane that also compresses the pressure
wave into a single shock wave that moves at
the speed of sound, commonly called Mach 1.
When the airplane goes faster than the speed
of sound it pierces through that barrier created
by the built up shock wave, creating a negative
pressure space around it.
The sonic boom is the sound associated with
the sudden change of pressure.
Engineers worked long and hard to get a plane
to fly through the so-called sound barrier
and go supersonic in level flight in the 1940s;
for years pilots trying to fly faster than
sound had airplane shake and break apart around
them thanks to those pressure waves.
It was Chuck Yeager piloting the X-1, which
was designed to look and fly like a bullet,
who first broke through that invisible wall
in the sky.
So how can a human make it through the sound
barrier without a perfectly aerodynamic rocket-powered
airplane?
There’s more to going supersonic than just
speed.
Altitude, and specifically the thickness of
the atmosphere at different altitudes, is
a major factor.
The higher the altitude the thinner the atmosphere,
which means there are fewer air molecules
for a plane, or a body, to get out of the
way.
Because extreme parachute jumpers like Felix
Baumgartner and Alan Eustace jumped and free
fell from such high altitudes, it was easier
for them to move air molecules out of the
way to hit Mach 1 because the air is less
dense.
Baumgartner didn’t need rockets to break
through the sound barrier falling from more
than 127,000 feet.
Yeager, flying the X-1 at 43,000 feet, on
the other hand, did need a rocket boost.
But interestingly, Baumgartner’s supersonic
moment required just 10 miles per hour less
than Yeager’s.
And, of course, specialized pressure suits
these jumpers wore play a big part.
Suits designed to protect the wearer from
the shock waves associated with the sound
barrier, even in less dense air, are vital
to success.
And not to mention survival.
So what do you guys think.
Would you make a supersonic jump?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of
the week.